the number of hate crimes across the
country is rising according to the
Center for the Study of hate and
extremism hate crimes jumped 12.5
percent last year in the nation's 10
largest cities it is the fourth
consecutive year the number has
increased CBS News senior national
security analyst Fran Townsend was
homeland security and counterterrorism
advisor for President George W Bush bush
Fran good morning you were in the White
House after 9/11 there was a discussion
at the highest levels of government
about how people are being radicalized
online in terms of terrorism now we have
homegrown extremists who are being
radicalized online in a different sort
of way
that's what can the government do about
that look we've struggled with this
right because we cherish our right to
free speech but we've tackled this
online with the social media sites in
the context of Islamic terrorism and as
you pointed out in one of the segments
earlier they have tackled this and so it
is possible the social media sites
they're now taking down gab why didn't
they do that earlier this is a cesspool
of sort of right-wing you know alt-right
nationalists there is a clear plot line
to be drawn about the motive that drew
the shooter against this he believed
there had been out that there was a
conspiracy out there that George Soros
who is a Hungarian billionaire of Jewish
faith was funding the migrant Caravan
that was on the front page of the
newspapers was front page over that
there were essentially Jews funding a
group of invaders and then and that was
not true right that thing not true yes
and then the Pittsburgh shooter posted
on gap I can't sit by and watch my
people get slaughtered screw your optics
I'm going in it's all there it is what's
radicalized that's wrong line by a
conspiracy so one of the things that
people don't appreciate is the FBI
doesn't monitor social media sites
they're restricted from doing that under
what's called the Attorney General
guidelines and so I think it's time that
we've got a look at that if people are
making these statements in public it's
sort of the town crier in the in local
square why can't the FBI look at it I
understand this the civil rights and
free speech concerns but I think it's
time we have to deal with the problem
that's in front of us and can they
forget it go ahead John
well the story Nora put forward so
completely is also being echoed from by
politicians from podiums in positions
which as Nick was talking about earlier
reinforces the what might just stay in a
dark place it's now out in the open
well let's talk about what politicians
are saying they're giving sort of
statements of condolence that's right
but what have they done to sort of look
at what's causing the problem right why
aren't we looking at the assault weapons
ban why are we looking at who gets
access to purchasing weapons this man
had 21 guns and he's posting this sort
of thing online why isn't it part of the
screening process to look at their
social media sites so I'm a little tired
of the politicians sort of messages of
condolences when they don't do any
screening process for buying a firearm
correct let me ask you this if you were
looking at threats in America right now
and you'd seen that 57 that the rise in
anti-semitic attacks had gone up 57% and
you're looking at all the threats in
America where would you put that in your
top well and let's let's point out one
in five of those is a religious bias
right this is the largest increase since
they've been recording these statistics
look I do think that the FBI has got a
look at how they arrayed their resources
not just them right but state and locals
and look at the domestic terrorism
threat all right Fran thanks so much for
being here as always